some pretty hot jewelry trends for
Valentine's gifts this year jumbo size
pearls a big specialty cocktail rings
too and something a little more
permanent as we connect with a female
owned business at the Container Park
cashing in on a big Trend this
Valentine's Day
I just love accessorizing I love fashion
look at this when the permanent jewelry
craze began trending on Tick Tock oh my
God 36 year old Cindy Lopez jumped on it
solidifying her in local permanent
jewelry business as a go-to destination
in Las Vegas right now it's 80 of my
business the majority of her customers
are tourists we do get a lot of couples
getting matching bracelets we've
actually had a lot of couples say that
they're replacing their promise rings
for permanent bracelets she also caters
to locals for family reunions birthday
celebrations galentines and Valentines
pretty slips and anklets are the most
popular the permanent jewelry Trend
picked up by The Tick Tock crowd has
forever improved the lives of those who
are always losing their precious jewels
it's a bracelet it's a chain that it's a
necklace that has no clasp and so it
just all the way around it's whatever
chain style you pick there might be a
pendant on it but yeah they literally
will weld it to or solder it together on
you so you you just wear it all the time
it's quick and 100 painless Cindy now
offers appointments and walk-ins at her
new location at the container park for a
trend she hopes has staying power and I
honestly don't see it going anywhere
now the jewelry shouldn't cause any
issues at the airport going through
security but as far as certain
diagnostic medical procedures like say
you have to get an MRI you would need to
remove it you can use jewelry shears or
even a bolt cutter and many Jewelers
offer the ability to get your bracelet
re-welded after the fact for a small fee